We will now begin our moment of silence
to pay our respects to John Lennon.
Lennon was walking in and this kid says, "John Lennon."
John was laying straight out like that.
No movement, nothing.
This guy just shot John Lennon.
The alleged killer is Mark David Chapman.
-Mark David Chapman.
Chapman is a photographer from Hawaii.
And why have you never spoke about it?
I just didn't want any trouble.
But time's past.
He actually apologized to us.
He said, gee I’m sorry I ruined your night
and I said you got to be kidding me, you just ruined your whole life.
Was somebody working with him?
Was it a conspiracy?
His intention was to bring fame to himself.
Was religion a motive?
He said my name is Mark David Chapman.
You’ll remember my name.
Nobody's ever given peace a complete chance.
Gandhi tried it, Martin Luther King tried it,
but they were shot.